y
[Música]
pública entiende lo que pasa es pública
no quiere sacar una playa pública
esta disputa entre algunos jóvenes y una
pareja tuvo lugar en la playa de ocean
park una exclusiva zona de puerto rico
isla que tiene el estatus de estado
libre asociado de estados unidos el
vídeo del altercado fue publicado el 25
de enero y se volvió viral nuestro
observador aquel vive en la zona explica
por ti
25 de enero hubo un grupo de muchachos
que estaban tratando de ejercitarse en
la
y una pareja que
allí mismo en la organización los ampays
le dijeron que no podía poner la casa y
porque le estaban bloqueando
su residencia
estimó tanto cancha y me dicen que yo lo
puedo montar cancha aquí me dicen que yo
no puedo mostrar cancha aquí porque ya
vive aquí
así que la señora le dijo a estos
muchachos que cuando ellos tuvieran un
millón de dólares ellos podían entonces
poner una casa de playa
muchas personas sintieron indignación y
bueno por esa razón el 29 de enero
tuvimos una manifestación a través de
golpe y a través de él salud que
llevamos el mensaje de que las playas
son del pueblo
[Aplausos]
estos altercados no se producen todos
los días pero desde hace algunos años
existe un movimiento llamado las playas
son del pueblo
este movimiento denuncia la
privatización de ciertas playas
vinculadas en particular a la
construcción de hoteles aunque se supone
que estas son de libre acceso los
activistas también denuncian el impacto
de estas construcciones en el medio
ambiente
hay muchas construcciones últimamente la
gota están construyendo
en la misma zona marítimo-terrestre
y dispone que es de dominio público y
pues eso genera
desastre ambiental por el ecosistema
tortugas en peligro de extinción que
habitan en nuestras playas en la misma
playa desamparo habilidades
tenemos que haréis también
tinte corales y ahora mismo es también
un riesgo desaparece y de que soy su
ecosistema se ha alterado por estas
construcciones a mediados del mes de
febrero los activistas defensores de las
playas obtuvieron una victoria el juez
anuló la licencia de construcción de una
piscina frente al mar en el municipio de
rincón
estas primas en esta nueva web
vivo en suecia desde hace 7 años se
llevaron a mi hija hace 3 años tengo
todas las pruebas vídeos documentos
judiciales que demuestran que no soy un
padre violento este padre sirio que vive
en suecia participó en una manifestación
contra los servicios de protección de la
infancia al igual que en las familias de
oriente medio han venido manifestándose
desde el mes de febrero para exigir el
regreso de sus hijos que fueron llevados
a familias de acogida
no hay mayor injusticia que separar a un
niño de su madre
estas protestas empezaron después de la
publicación de vídeos en las redes
sociales con el hashtag dejen de
secuestrar a nuestros niños en estos
vídeos los padres acusan a los servicios
sociales de apartar a sus hijos de la
religión musulmana a dar a la abogada de
familia explica lo que dice la ley sueca
evidentemente derechazo la palabra
secuestro porque se trata de acoger al
niño hasta que la situación de la
familia deje de ser peligrosa la ley
también garantiza un abogado para el
padre y la madre y un abogado para el
niño también es posible presentar un
recurso ante un tribunal administrativo
y luego ante la corte suprema para
impugnar la decisión
la legislación sueca le permite a los
servicios sociales solicitar la acogida
temporal de un niño en caso de maltrato
físico o psicológico pero también si los
padres no tienen los medios para
mantenerse
los padres aceptan cooperar con los
servicios sociales se puede optar para
que el niño sea acogido por una familia
que haga parte de su tejido social como
una guía unquillo
los servicios sociales investigan a
partir de una habitación que puede
proceder del colegio el hospital la
guardería el propio niño o los vecinos
lo que también me gustaría mencionar es
que a menudo existe una falta de
confianza entre las autoridades y los
padres migrantes
y esta última campaña corre el riesgo de
agravar esta brecha y la falta de
confianza entre las autoridades y los
padres
por otro lado a veces estas familias no
se les trata bien
especialmente cuando tienen que lidiar
con un empleado que tiene prejuicios
y el ministerio de relaciones exteriores
de suecia reaccionó en twitter
denunciando una campaña de
desinformación el consejo sueco de
imanes le pidió a sus integrantes que
hicieran todo lo posible para
contrarrestar la difusión del discurso
de odio
también le pidió que investigaran a los
funcionarios de los servicios sociales
sospechosos de cometer abusos
es todo por esta semana de los
observadores de france 24 si ustedes
quieren comunicarse con la producción
del programa nuestros puntos de contacto
aparecen en sus pantallas queremos
agradecer a dios a cervecería y matorral
librería por haber sido nuestra locación
el día de hoy nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana hasta entonces